the mission on opportunity which the
next Labor government will deliver Kia
stalma
in Medway to unveil the fifth and final
mission of a future labor government I
promise you this whatever the obstacles
to opportunity wherever the barriers to
hope my labor government will tear them
down pledging to break the class ceiling
a political priority and a personal one
too I see this Mission as our core
purpose
and my personal cause
to fight at every stage for every child
the pernicious idea that background
equals Destiny but in the background
accusations from activists
but he's going back on green investment
plans will you just let me finish this
handling the hecklers before getting
back to his mission that a child starts
in life won't determine where they end
up but clear too he won't back up
promises with big increases in public
funds will you commit to more investment
for schools and education ahead of the
next general election we can't hide from
the fact we're going to inherit a really
damaged economy after 13 years of
failure can't hide the fact that we're
going to inherit failed public services
and we have to take hard decisions
leaving a hard reality for pressed
Public Services the point I'm trying to
make to you is that it has to be
Evolution not Revolution because you
simply don't have the resources to
deliver it fast well look is that fair
though I've not pretended that we can
snap our fingers on this and we're
absolutely clear that this is our
priority we can make the changes one of
those changes to bring the standards of
private and state schools closer
together by when well as soon as we can
and that's the first time of the labor
government takes two labor governments
takes a generation by when this is
intended to set out what I would hope to
have achieved in five years of a labor
government maybe a little bit more
attentive promise for a labor
government's fast term but those in the
sector from schools to vocational
colleges all too aware of the pressures
at play I think we're all realists to
understand that it's going to be
difficult because there isn't money and
we're in a long queue with lots of other
people but the fact that education is
starting to come square and Center is
really encouraging
missions into concrete pledges later
this year Beth Rigby Sky News jillianum
in Kent